Olá boa noite a todos vocês Prazer em
tlos conosco para mais uma live Estamos
aqui hoje para falar da Ferritina o
significado desse exame tão importante
pra saúde o significado dessa proteína
para que que ela serve na nossa saúde
seja muito sejam muito bem-vindos a mais
uma live aqui no canal eu tenho aqui do
meu lado Dr Ana Paula Rodrigues que vai
participar da Live também vai dar as
suas opiniões as suas informações
importantes para todos vocês então esse
tema da Ferritina é um tema muito
importante para nossa saúde e nós vamos
falar tanto da condição da ferritina
baixa quanto a condição da Ferritina
alta Você já ouviu falar sobre isso é
importante para nós a Ferritina é uma
proteína crucial pro nosso organismo
pois ela armazena o ferro Então mas o
que que acontece com a gente quando os
níveis de ferritina estão acima do
normal é sobre isso que nós vamos falar
hoje nós vamos entender os níveis de
fertila no nosso corpo porque que eles
são
fundamentais e também esse exame pode
indicar várias condições de saúde
algumas delas são bastante sérias vamos
conhecer as causas os sintomas os
tratamentos da fitina alta e aí você vai
entender como você pode buscar atenção
médica já com as informações prontas
para para que você possa conduzir esse
tratamento da melhor forma possível com
o seu médico então o que que é Ferritina
vamos começar falando que é Ferritina e
a Dra Ana Paula tá convidada a
interromper em qualquer momento aí a
minha explicação e dar suas próprias
contribuições a Ferritina é uma proteína
que armazena o ferro nas nossas células
ela age como um depósito de ferro e ela
vai liberando esse ferro depositado
conforme o corpo vai necessitando e sem
a Ferritina o nosso corpo teria muita
dificuldade em gerenciar o ferro porque
o ferro é um mineral que apesar de ser
essencial ser muito importante é um
mineral complicado porque ele em excesso
também aumenta o stress oxidativo então
é como se ele fosse um combustível
nuclear né é uma maneira de explicar né
uma analogia porque o ferro seria
deixado solto no organismo ele começa a
se juntar com outras moléculas de ox
gênio em forma o que a gente chama de
reação de fenton que é um estress
oxidativo muito importante então o ferro
tem que ser conduzido com muita cautela
pelo corpo o corpo tem que ter vários
mecanismos de lidar com isso para que
não aconteça a situação do ferro está
gerando esse stress oxidativo essas
formas de radicais livres que vão
destruindo várias moléculas nas células
então a Ferritina é importante muito
importante como o depósito de ferro e
ela vai liberando o ferro para várias
funções do organismo entre elas a
formação do m o m é uma proteína muito
importante na hemoglobina para carregar
o oxigênio e também para outras
hemoproteínas ou outras proteínas que
usam ferro eh para o seu
metabolismo Então por que que o
armazenamento de ferro é tão importante
o ferro é vital paraa produção e pro
transporte do o oxigênio ele é utilizado
então para hemoglobina poder carregar
esse elemento tão essencial à vida então
a hemoglobina vai carregar o oxigênio
dos pulmões para o resto do corpo paraas
células utilizando para isso a
hemoglobina e na hemoglobina tem o ferro
na sua composição Além disso o ferro ele
é necessário pro crescimento pro
desenvolvimento normal do organismo
paraa função celular paraa síntese de
vários hormônios então quando os níveis
de Ferro estão fora estão para baixo
demais ou para alto demais estão fora do
equilíbrio seja por excesso por
deficiência isso pode causar vários
problemas de saúde exemplo quando o
ferro tá baixo no organismo quando a
Ferritina está baixa no organismo é
muito comum a pessoa ter disfunção
tiroidiana tiroide depende do ferro para
funcionar então é muito comum uma pessoa
que tá com o ferro muito baixo na forma
de ferritina isso é muito comum em
mulheres né que tá com Ferritina de oito
retina de 10 ela começa a ficar
fadigada porque ela não consegue
primeiro carregar oxigênio de uma
maneira eficiente porque tá com menos
hemoglobina nas suas hemácias ela fica
com hemácia tem inclusive até menos
vermelha ela fica com uma massa
hipocrômica com menos vermelhão porque o
vermelhão vem do grupo M que tem
hemoglobina e também a tireoide dessa
mulher passa a trabalhar de uma maneira
menos eficiente quer acrescentar alguma
coisa Dona Paula bem boa noite a todos e
primeiro eu queria agradecer o convite
né Foi muito bom E e essa ideia de
esclarecer melhor o que é Ferritina alta
O que é ferritina baixa veio
principalmente depois de um um vídeo eh
do meu Instagram e que viralizou teve aí
tá perto de 100.000 views e que muitas
perguntas surgiram e eu acho importante
a gente responder não só para quem fez a
pergunta mas também abranger um grupo de
pessoas né então foi muito legal essa
essa interação com os internautas e ver
o quanto ainda a gente tem de de dúvidas
né que sobre o ferro a Ferritina o papel
deles no nosso organismo a importância
principalmente como você disse nos
processos aí de transporte de oxigênio
de cicatrização de estress oxidativo da
área hormonal de cicatrização né falando
na parte cirúrgica aí uma uma mulher
anêmica uma mulher que tá tendo um
sangramento importante também da da na
área menstrual ela pode ter uma um
prejuízo de cicatrização pode ter aí a
gente se preocupa muito com a questão
capilar muitas mulheres têm queda
capilar por alterações do ferro seja uma
anemia ou seja um padrão inflamatório
quando ela tá com a Ferritina muito alta
por uma questão inflamatória e um
pré-diabetes um hipotiroidismo uma
resistência Clínica aumentada uma dieta
ruim
tá e o cuidado realmente porque virou
uma panaceia H se repor ferro
principalmente endovenoso isso tem que
se tomar muito cuidado né em como também
você vai prescrever o ferro para esse
paciente e como você pode orientar
alimentos que ele pode incluir aí na
dieta e tomar bastante cuidado das
pessoas que TM restrição dos principais
alimentos principalmente a carne
vermelha e que pode estar aí com um
déficit de Ferro contínuo e tendo vários
sintomas inclusive vasculares inclusive
edema ou o excesso do ferro que pode dar
dermatite Ocre que a gente também tem
outro vídeo aqui então é importante a
gente tentar esclarecer para que você
tenha um Norte aí para est para Tá
conversando com quem é o teu
profissional para est ajustando aí as
pontas soltas né perfeito eu acho que é
um bom momento pra gente começar a
responder algumas dúvidas coisas que eu
já até comentei aqui estão sendo
perguntadas isentão vai ser um uma uma
resposta bem rápida para algumas
perguntas perguntas aqui que estão sendo
colocadas tá diferença entre Ferritina e
ferro Ferritina é uma proteína ferro é
um mineral a Ferritina é uma proteína
que carrega e armazena ferro e quando
você vai precisar utilizar o ferro a
fertina libera o ferro de volta pro
sangue na forma livre basicamente isso
como se fosse um táxi do ferro como se
fosse um táxi talvez até uma mistura de
táxi com armazenamento como se fosse um
é o táxi mas também é um
depósito um galpão né Porque também tem
a transferrina né que é uma outra
proteína que carrega ferro que a função
dela é mais é transportar e a Ferritina
é mais de armazenar o que que acontece
com o ferro se não tivermos ferritina no
corpo então a Ferritina ela vai estar
baixa quando você tiver o ferro baixo no
organismo ela tá ligado a quantidade de
ferro que você tem se tem pouco ferro
vai ter pouca Ferritina E na verdade a
Ferritina como marcador ela é muito mais
fidedigno do que o ferro livre no sangue
tá a transferrina como eu acabei de
mencionar é uma proteína de transporte e
que ela tem uma uma outra função
enquanto que a a feritina é mais de
armazenamento a transferina é de
transporte então quando precisa de ferro
no organismo a fertina libera esse ferro
e a transferina pode transportar ela
para outros tecidos tá hemoglobina Eu já
falei é o principal elemento que usa o
ferro na sua composição o a hemoglobina
é uma é uma proteína complexa tem várias
unidades e ela tem uma parte central
chama-se grupo m e nesse grupo m tem um
ferro bem no meio dela
tá o ideal é fazer ferro Ferritina e
transferrina e capacidade de fixação do
ferro tá Esses são os exames ideais você
fazer pode falar né não isso mesmo são
quatro exames
é ecesso de fertina pode significar
principalmente inflamação nós vamos
falar ao longo dessa Live tá o acord
você tem uma inflamação o corpo para se
defender ele aumenta os depósito de
ferritina então a Ferritina quando está
alta É principalmente sinal de
inflamação Mas pode significar também
uma dân chamada hemocromatose nós vamos
falar isso ao longo da
Live não tem casos de ferritina baixa
que se resolvem com eh simplesmente
aumento de proteína na na alimentação À
vezes tem pessoas que tem ferritina
baixa não por ferro eh não só porque o
ferro tá baixo mas também por
deficiência de proteína
sim o vegano sofre com mais deficiência
de Ferro do que pessoas que comem carne
não necessariamente carnívoros
né vamos pular para outras perguntas
vamos pular aqui para porque aqui tem
coisas que ainda vão ser faladas né vai
ficar redundante ex isso
exatamente Bem pessoal vamos continuar
aqui tá Agora que nós já sabemos o que
que é Ferritina para que que ela serve a
sua importância vamos entender o que que
significa ter níveis Altos de de
ferritina no no sangue e também baixos e
quais são as possíveis causas e sintomas
dessa situação tá então os valores de
ferritina no sangue variam de homens
para mulheres tá os homens tendem a ter
a Ferritina mais alta no sangue do que
as mulheres Isso é uma pergunta que é
muito
eh feita pelos pacientes e também pelos
internautas qual é o nível bom de fitina
a gente lembra que existe uma
característica individual segundo de
idade as mulheres que ainda estão
menstruando T um nível Ferritina ótimo
enquanto as que não menstruam mais então
tem que tomar muito cuidado e lembra que
o o o o Core né o ali o Range
Laboratorial Varia muito às vezes até de
laboratório para laboratório então não
fixar no número mas sempre no padrão
individual de cada paciente é tem kits
diferentes no mercado Então tem que
ficar atento quanto a isso né de uma
maneira grosseira bem grosseira tá e não
quero que vocês levem isso a ferro e
fogo Ah o nível de fertina em mulher vai
ser mais ou menos entre 20 e 200 e homem
entre 20 e 400 Tá mas de modo geral a
ferritina no no homem é mais alta do que
mulheres porque o homem não menstrua e a
mulher por menstruar e perder sangue
Todo mês a os níveis de ferritina vão
ser mais baixos Ok
ã então quando a Ferritina passa desses
valores na mulher é por volta de 200 no
homem por volta de 300 350 você começa a
ter o excesso de ferro e esse excesso de
Ferro começa a Gerar estress oxidativo e
também pode significar uma inflamação
crônica né então ter Ferritina Alta ou
hiperferritinemia significa que tem um
excesso de Ferro armazenado no corpo ou
um excesso de inflamação e se for por
excesso de Ferro ele pode ser indicativo
de várias condições subjacentes e que
pode levar para problema sério se não
for tratado for adequadamente avaliado
por um médico por uma médica é um sinal
de que algo não está funcionando bem no
metabolismo do ferro então causa de
feritina alta depois a gente vai falar
causa de fertina baixa tá problemas no
fígado doenças hepáticas como hepatites
de modo geral Hepatite viral hepatite
medicamentosa hepatite por uso de álcool
hepatite por excesso de gordura no
fígado né E se essa hepatite piorar
progredir pode levar inclusive a cirros
que é a substituição do tecido hepático
por tecido fibroso hepatite autoimune e
autoimune ótimo bem muito bem lembrado
pela D Ana Paula uma das causas mais
comuns de feritina alta são as doenças
hepáticas como acabei de mencionar o
fígado é um órgão fundamental na
regulação do ferro e quando ele está
doente pode acontecer o acúmulo de
ferritina então outra causa inflamação
crônica e infecções processos
inflamatórios crônicos e infecções
podem aumentar elevar os níveis de
ferritina Porque durante a inflamação o
corpo aumenta a produção de ferritina
para compensar para tentar combater essa
inflamação e isso acaba aumentando os
níveis no sangue Além disso tem uma
doença relativamente Rara tá que é a
hemocromatose uma doença genética em que
o corpo absorve ferro em excesso da
alimentação e esse ferro Extra ele é
armazenado como Ferritina levando a
níveis muito altos que podem causar
danos aos órgãos ao longo do tempo OK
doenças autoimunes pode o ferro é
absorvido a nível intestinal e
Geralmente as pessoas com hemocromatose
familiar Tem um um um uma um aumento de
10 até alguns autores falam em 50 vezes
da absorção Então vamos dizer se você o
absorvia 10 moléculas de Ferro uma
pessoa com hemocromatose 100 a 500 por
dia então você tem um aumento do fluxo
de Ferro paraa corrente sanguínea pro
fígado e ele não consegue manejar isso
ele vai acabando estocando tanto a nível
de fígado a nível de suprarrenal adrenal
a nível de Basso né a nível de outros
tecidos eh internos a nível de de
sistema eh vascular você vê aquelas
pernas escuras né que é dermatite Ocre
então um paciente com hemocromatose a a
a Gênese do problema é uma absorção
muito maior do que seria o normal tá E
isso hoje
pode-se pesquisar famílias que tenham
por exemplo caso de cirrose essa
dermatite Ocre algumas outras questões
ligados ao ferro você faz a a busca
gênica aí a pesquisa genética do da
Mutação aí do do m
né então algumas doenças autoimunes
também podem causar elevação na
Ferritina porque essas doenças fazem que
o sistema de defesa o sistema imune
ataque o próprio corpo causando
inflamação essa inflamação S por
consequência aumenta a Ferritina outra
causa muito comum no nosso meio né em
outros países também é o consumo
excessivo de álcool nós sabemos Todos
nós sabemos que o álcool em excesso pode
prejudicar o fígado causar um acúmulo de
ferritina e isso obviamente é uma causa
evitável e controlável dessa condição
pessoas também que recebem muitas
transfusões de sangue pessoas que TM
doenças que exigem muita transfusão pode
acumular ferro no organismo e também
aumentar os níve de de
ferritina Então existe uma anemia eh que
é de nascencia uma anemia genética que é
muito comum na região do Mediterrâneo
que é a
talassemia e Dependendo da forma dessa
talassemia ela pode precisar tomar
várias transfusões de sangue e se for
uma talassemia Major né uma talassemia
mais acentuada e essas repetidas
transfusões podem elevar o nível de
ferritina também no organismo né Então
quais são os sintomas de uma pessoa que
tem Ferritina alta a principal
eh situação aí é a fadiga sentir-se
constantemente cansado Pode ser sim um
sinal de que algo não está bem então é
engraçado também que pode ser sintoma de
baixa de feritina também né pessoas com
fetina muito baixa como eu comentei tá
associado ao funcionamento inadequado da
tireoide tá associado à anemia Então
essas duas condições levam também a
fadiga então tanto ferritina baixa
quanto Ferritina alta pode levar a
sensação de cansaço crônico pacientes
oncológicos né podem ter também as duas
vertentes né No início pode ter um
aumento de ferritina pelo processo
inflamatório e depois pelo processo
consuntivo pelo aumento do tumor né pelo
pelos tratamentos Associados cirúrgicos
quimioterápicos radioterápicos ele pode
sair de uma Ferritina de padrão
inflamatório entre aspas oncológico e
descer aí para uma fertina baixa então é
importante monitorar no paciente
oncológico a questão da
Ferritina com certeza muito importante
então outro sintoma de ferritina alta
são dores nas articulações o excesso de
ferro pode se depositar nessas regiões
nas juntas causando dor e desconforto o
outro sintoma é dor abdominal
Especialmente na área próxima ao fígado
aqui no na parte direita baixo da
costela isso pode indicar problemas
relacionados a Ferritina alta o o fígado
pode estar sobrecarregado ou inflamado
devido a excesso de Ferro Então os
problemas no fígado são tanto uma causa
quanto consequência causa da situação da
Ferritina alta quanto um sintoma da
própria Ferritina alta o fígado pode
apresentar sinais de dano ou de algum
tipo de disfunção pode ter problemas na
pele também uma
hiperpigmentação então a pele pode ficar
com uma área
escurecida hiperpigmentada
devido ao acúmulo de Ferro fica mais
escuro especialmente nas áreas expostas
ao sol né Quer comentar sobre isso é
então é muito comum né os pacientes
procurarem o dermatologista inicialmente
ou Clínico h para fazer uma pesquisa um
tratamento daquelas pernas escuras
geralmente que é chamado de dermatite
Ocre né que é o depósito de Ferro aí
nesse tecido
ã circunferencial né do joelho para
baixo e que muitas vezes não adianta
você usar um creme ou fazer um peeling
você tem que procurar se esse paciente
tem uma dermatiti por alteração de
ferritina ou se ele tem essa dermatiti
procre por exemplo por uma por um quadro
varicoso por um quadro linfático então
varizes insuficiência safena Preguiçosa
né um linfedema uma Erisipela de
repetição ela pode fazer uma inflamação
no local e causar uma dermatite e ou o
paciente que tem uma alteração da
Ferritina também então é importante
sempre o paciente que tem essa perna
escura que parece uma meia ela começa
com pequenos pontinhos depois vai se
juntando fazer uma pesquisa também tanto
da Saúde hepática né as enzimas
hepáticas TGO TGP B rubina Gama GT fazer
um bom ultrassom avaliar o os grupos aí
né transferrina saturação Ferritina
ferro cérico Como é que tá a parte
metabólica para esclarecer se essa
dermatite é somente um quadro vascular é
um quadro metabólico ou ambos E
lembrando que essa dermatite ela começa
a ficar escura essa pele começa a ter
uma inflamação ela fica com uma
consistência tipo primeiro uma casca de
tangerina depois uma casca de árvore e
pode descamar e com o tempo abrir
pequenas feridinhas também então o
tratamento tem que ser conjunto tanto da
parte metabólica quanto da parte
vascular quando você tem as duas doenças
tem uma pergunta aqui que a gente de
certa forma já respondeu mas é bom te
reforçar como a fertin alta é um
marcador de inflamação como eu falei já
algumas vezes Paulo também retificou
Você pode muito bem ter fertina alta
hemoglobina baixa ou normal não é
verdade é totalmente possível e você ter
uma hemoglobina normal com a fertina
alta Espero que você tenha entendido
esse conceito viu mas a gente pode est
respondendo outras perguntas
relacionadas quem está com atina alta
depositada no fígado né Tem remédio para
esse tipo de problema Quer comentar bem
primeiro identificar como é que é a
dieta desse paciente às vezes é um
paciente que é extremamente carnívoro né
a gente sabe que em algumas regiões do
Brasil existe aí um um um consumo muito
grande de carne então avaliar a dieta
segundo medicamentos que a pessoa esteja
em uso que possam causar uma alteração
eh do fígado e que levem a uma disfunção
terceiro se essa mulher por exemplo usou
algum medicamento da parte ginecológica
que pode ter inflamado o fígado também
levando a uma alteração da Ferritina e
existe sim primeiro regulação da dieta
segundo tem alguns suplementos muito
bacanas existem alguns Element algun
perdão alguns alimentos que você pode
incluir para ajudar nessa questão da
Ferritina e importante o quê se essa
Ferritina ela tá ligada a alguma doença
né Marlene se você tá numa menopausa se
você tá com alteração de peso se você tá
com hipotiroidismo medicamento se você
tem feito consumo de álcool se você tem
eh uma dieta muito rica em carboidrato
Então tá aí com uma entre aspas
pré-diabetes Então vê se não tem nenhuma
doença sistêmica que tá fazendo alterar
o o o fígado Tá bom mas existe sim
organização de dieta de bons hábitos
algumas suplementações e em casos muito
importantes e níveis de ferritina
estejam mais elevados a gente orienta o
qu as sangrias ou as programadas ou as
transfusões tá bom É aí a a gente se
adiantou um pouco no assunto né do
tratamento Mas não tem problema a gente
pode voltar nessas nesses tópicos aí
vamos falar um pouquinho sobre o impacto
na saúde da feritina alta né como é que
ela pode afetar diferentes órgãos e
sistemas quando ela tá alta no nosso
organismo isso geralmente é excesso de
ferro ou inflamação ou as duas coisas
juntas Então isso que é um pouco confuso
na fertina alta ela pode significar
inflamação excesso de ferro ou as duas
coisas juntos então ela é um marcador
misto né Assim como um sist como se tem
né também um marcador misto pode pegar
inflamação e também déficit de metilação
então Infelizmente o corpo é é às vezes
complexo né tem que avaliar de uma
maneira mais abrangente Então esse
excesso de ferro quando a fertina está
alta pode se acumular em vários órgãos
levando a problemas disfunções a longo
prazo e por exemplo pode causar um risco
aumentado de doenças cardíacas o o ferro
em excesso pode se depositar no coração
causando um negócio chamado
cardiomiopatia que é a doença do músculo
do coração e que enfraquece esse músculo
ele fica dilatado e
enfraquecido isso pode levar arritmias
os batimentos cardíacos de forma
irregular e em caso mais grave sência
cardíaca e outras complicações cardíacas
graves já comentamos aqui do fígado
vamos falar um pouco mais sobre isso o
acúmulo de ferritina no fígado eh pode
levar uma condição chamada
hemosiderose isso se for muito acentuado
pode evoluir paraa cirrose hepática que
é a substituição dos das células do
fígado por tecido fibroso né que é um
tecido que não tem a mesma função do
fígado pode levar IMP crônica até câncer
de fígado isso pode acontecer também
então o fígado danificado não pode eh
Aliás ele não consegue se cicatrizar de
uma maneira correta né como ele é um
órgão que normalmente se cicatriza se
consegue se regenerar de uma maneira
muito
fácil mas com esse ferro acumulado ele
não consegue funcionar de forma adequada
resultando em problemas metabólicos e
também em detox deficiente o excesso de
ferro também pode afetar o pâncreas ele
pode acumular no pâncreas interferir na
produção de insulina isso pode levar até
um diabetes secundário um diabetes tipo
dois por excesso de Ferro então pessoas
que TM
hemocromatose que é essa doença genética
nós comentamos que é uma das causas de
feritina alta não é mais comum mas é uma
causa bem importante ela frequentemente
desenvolve diabetes como uma complicação
dessa hemocromatose e também pode levar
disturbios hormonais para fertina alta
tanto a baixa quanto a alta falei que a
fertina baixa pode dar problema de
funcionamento tiroidiano e a fertina
alta pode também afetar a hipófise pode
acumular na hipófise que é uma glândula
que tá atrás dos olhos aqui no pé do
cérebro isso pode resultar em problemas
como hipogonadismo Ou seja você tem uma
falta de produção de hormônio sexual das
gônadas seja testículo em homem ovário
em mulher porque a hipófise já não manda
um sinal não manda os hormônios LH e FSH
corretamente para para as glândulas para
para as gônadas e isso vai reduzir os
hormônios sexuais disfunção tiroidiana
como eu já falei também alterações
também nos níveis de cortisol então para
diagnosticar a Ferritina tanto Alto
quanto baixa o primeiro passo é realizar
um exame de sangue vocês conhecem o
exame de ferritina sérica ele é um exame
relativamente simples e direto e você já
comentou aqui os quatro exames Eu também
já comentei os quatro exames que a gente
pode pedir para avaliar todo o
metabolismo do ferro
eh eh você pode pedir outros exames
complementares também para avaliar esse
excesso de Ferro isso pode incluir
exames de função hepática para ver as
enzimas do fígado TGO TGP Gam GT
fosfatas alcalina biópsia né em alguns
casos se o fígado tiver muito
comprometido tiver sinais de cirrose ou
de hepatite crônica ou até suspeita de c
pode ser necessário fazer biópsia do
fígado exames de imagem tem ultrassom
que a Dora Paula especialista em
ultrassom ela vai comentar com vocês
aqui existe um exame de ultra especial
do fígado para avaliar se esse fígado
está ou não com eh fibrose ou se ele
está com um processo de de cirrose e uma
ressonância magnética também para
avaliar a presença de Ferro dentro do
fígado e nos outros órgãos comenta sobre
o tipo de ultra especial que existe ao
fibroscan lá para verificar isso aí isso
h o o depósito de de ferro no fígado
como o doutor disse tem um processo de
inflamação essa inflamação pode ir de
Branda até muito grave e essa muito
grave Você tem uma transformação das
células do fígado certo num tecido como
se fosse uma cicatriz que é chamada
cirrose isso pode acontecer na hepatite
B na hepatite C nas outras hepatites
autoimunes numa hepatite alco de longa
data outros tipos de doenças também que
acometem no fígado tá bom
ã para evitar a biópsia tem um exame que
chama fibra Scan no qual você faz um
ultrassom que ele tem um software que vê
a dureza desse órgão e ele vai fazendo o
quê vai graduando essa dureza e de
acordo com isso existe um relatório tá o
fibris é o mais famoso acho que um dos
primeiros foi na escola pol medicina
principalmente para tá o qu a biópsia em
pacientes que tinham hepatite C que
necessitariam por exemplo de transplante
ou que necessitariam de um protocolo né
de medicamentos e a gente sabe que
biópsia hepática é uma biópsia que é
complicado de você gerenciar a maioria
desses pacientes têm problemas de
coagulação sangram muito então não era
difícil você ir com trassom fazer a
biópsia esse paciente começar a sangrar
você precisar ir pro sangue cirúrgico e
às vezes acontecer até um desfecho não
legal então houve desenvolvimento deste
H tipo tipo de ultrassom no qual você
consegue realmente ter um um um padrão
um espelhamento muito bom e saber como é
que tá
e a hora que você tem que agir nessa
nessa patologia hepática tá fora isso
existem hoje aparelhos já no Brasil
desse ultrassom que você já fez mas que
ele tem esse software que chama
elastografia tá em que você através de
ondas de choque você não sente a dor
nada mas o aparelho manda ondas e essa
onda bate e volta e conforme ela bate e
volta ela vai vendo se esse órgão tá
macio ou não a elastografia não é só
usada pro fígado mas é o padrão Ouro da
elasto assim você usa também hoje para
nódulos de tireoide para nódulos de mama
e para próstata tá isso tá ganhando uma
amplitude as principais firmas de
ultrassom já estão embutindo no
ultrassom os cursos de formação no
Brasil já estão ficando mais robustos e
é um exame que é indolor não tem
contraste e ajuda muito no
acompanhamento aí tanto de eh nódulos
benignos né suspeitas de malignos mas
também no fígado para ver se esse fígado
ele tá macio se ele tá duro e se tá na
hora realmente de entrar com protocolos
aí para para se
Rosa perfeito né explicação excelente a
d Ana Paula como sempre né
Eh então é muito importante ter um
diagnóstico preciso paraa gente poder
tratar adequadamente nessa ftina alta
paa já comentou aqui de alguns exames
que são importantes para isso
identificar a causa é fundamental pra
gente poder tratar da melhor forma
possível prevenir complicações né então
é muito importante Esses exames
complementares pro diagnóstico correto e
preciso a gente poder também evitar os
danos irreversíveis que podem acontecer
aos órgãos vamos falar então do
tratamento de como gerenciar essa
condição é fundamental mudança no estilo
de vida mudança de dieta
mudança inclusive se a pessoa tiver
hábito de beber álcool ela reduzir ou
cessar o uso do álcool né Então temos
que ajustar a a dieta balanceada para
que possa ter uma dieta não inflamatória
e eu tô cansado de falar no canal sobre
isso é uma dieta que vai ter pouco
carboidrato e esse carboidrato que tem
na dieta tem que ser um carboidrato de
qualidade um carboidrato que seja eh de
digestão lenta um carboidrato natural e
não refinado não processado a alimentos
que não seja eh também processados e
também evitar pessoas que têm tendência
a ferro alto a feritina alta evitar os
alimentos fortificados com ferro e não
precisa nem falar né também reduzir ou
evitar o consumo de álcool né porque o
álcool em pessoas que T tendência ou que
já tem af Ferritina alta vai piorar a
sobrecarga de Ferro especialmente
pessoas que já tem uma tendência a
doença no fígado então a dieta com
vegetais coloridos né vegetal vermelho
vegetal laranja vegetal Verde vegetal
roxo e os polifenóis dos alimentos dos
vegetais vão dar diferentes elementos
diferentes substâncias que vão dar
comida pras bactérias do intestino Você
tem uma alimentação então rica em
vegetais que crescem acima do solo
cortar a o carboidrato refinado cortar o
álcool cortar a frutose que tá nos
alimentos processados industrializados
na forma do xarope de eh de milho de
alta
frutose beber água de maneira adequada
fazer atividade física adequada dormir
adequadamente gerenciar o estresse tudo
isso é muito importante tá vamos falar
então dos tratamentos mais específicos
Dr an Paula já comentou da flebotomia
que é o que você tirar sangue dessa
pessoa é um tratamentos mais clássicos
aí que a gente tem quando a fertina está
muito alta a gente pode poder a gente
pode retirar parte do sangue dessa
pessoa e vai tirar o ferro junto com
essa fomia com essa esse procedimento
pode também doar sangue se essa pessoa
for saudável e suficiente ela vai doar
sangue e dessa maneira ela vai se livrar
do excesso de ferro de
ferritina então a flebotomia que nós
comentamos é a retirada regular de
sangue pode ser de 200 300 ml uma vez
por mês mais ou menos isso pode ajudar
bastante a reduzir os estoques de Ferro
medicamentos quelantes de ferro podem
ser utilizados em algumas circunstân S
medicamentos que vão tirar o ferro do
organismo isso pode ser utilizado também
Especialmente na hemosiderose na na
hemocromatose e fazer um monitoramento
regular desses níveis de ferritina
depois de iniciar o tratamento é
essencial monitorar regularmente os
níveis de ferritina para garantir que
eles estão diminuindo e permanecendo
dentro da faixa normal e para as pessoas
também que TM Ferritina alta por conta
de inflamação tem que descobrir a causa
da inflamação e tratar essa inflamação
pode ser uma infecção pode ser um uma
uma CDO metabólica uma pessoa que está
obesa uma pessoa que está com excesso de
trigliceridos no sangue uma pessoa que
está com excesso de açúcar no sangue tá
com pressão arterial aumentada tá com a
circunferência abdominal aumentada Então
essa situação da síndrome metabólica tem
que ser abordado para a pessoa poder
desinflamar e muitas vezes tem que
associar os tratamentos fazer o
tratamento para desinflamar a pessoa e
ao mesmo tempo também tirar os excesso
de sangue excesso de Ferro dessa pessoa
sua cumprimenta aí não e falando sobre
transfusão também é uma pergunta né
existem critérios muito rigorosos para
transfusão de sangue você tem que
procurar o Hemocentro da sua cidade ou o
hospital para que você veja direitinho e
sempre sobre prescrição médica né e uma
coisa importante sempre que a gente fala
em live a gente vê ah mas eh Esses
exames são caros Ah mas é difícil não
Esses exames de sangue são exames são
bem padr sincronizados exames que você
faz no posto de saúde que você faz no
convênio que você faz particular com
baixo custo então se você conseguir
fazer um pul dos exames de função
hepática e os de função de ferro e um
ultrassom de abdômen você já vai est aí
bem calçado com um um kit pequeno de
exames para direcionar Como é que tá a
sua situação de ferro e de ferritina
Alta ou baixa no seu organismo tá então
aqui não tem nenhum exame mirabolante
esses outros exames que a gente comentou
são para casos em que você tem já seja
uma doença genética pré-estabelecida ou
uma lesão mais grave né uma esteatose
grau TR um quatro suspeito de cirrose um
quatro suspeito de hemocromatose um
paciente que tem uma hepatite autoimune
uma hepatite C e B que precise de uma
biópsia então ter isso bem em mente tá
bom então de qualquer lugar do Brasil
que você seja o o padrão seu de de de
acesso à saúde isso são exames que podem
ser feitos de uma maneira muito
tranquila bem aqui tem alguns números
que eu não vou analisar esses números
porque isso não é adequado dentro de uma
live Mas pode dar uma orientação para
essa pessoa aí ela tem tiroidite de
Hashimoto né E ela quer saber se
compensa repor ferro mesmo com a
transferrina baixa Quer
comentar Olha é importante irite
Hashimoto então é um quadro autoimune né
a gente sabe que ele realmente tem um um
uma questão metabólica importante e uma
avaliação nutricional um pouquinho mais
robusta seria importante antes de você
fazer a reposição de Ferro
perfeito
é então tá Pessoal vocês estão colocando
números de exames aqui a gente tem que
orientar vocês que por questões legais e
por questões éticas eu não posso ficar
analisando exame no meio de uma live tá
isso aqui é para fazer orientações
Gerais tá então eu não vou ficar
analisando nem an Paula os números que
vocês estão apresentando
porque não seria nemum pouco adequado
fazer isso tá
eh pode gerar problemas pra gente na
questão do canal e da Live tá gente
exatamente questão do canal da questão
do Conselho de medicina também que fica
monitorando esses canais médicos Tá
então não não tentem eu sei que vocês
fazem isso de bom coração e tudo mas não
tentem ficar pedindo para analisar
números tá se a neuropediatra disse que
não precisa repor tá eh primeiro que tem
que analisar a a a realmente a Ferritina
eu não entendi eu acho que você colocou
ferrite aqui mas deve ser Ferritina mas
eu não vou analisar esse número mas a
princípio siga as orientações da
neuropediatra
tá
Ah vamos ver para uma última
pergunta minha Ferritina está muito alta
tive dengue há um mês atrás porque eu
porém o ferro está muito muito baixo eu
fazia suplementação de ferro Mas o
médico mandou parar pois pode aumentar a
Ferritina Depende francel se o ferro
tiver baixo e a fertina baixa você deve
fazer sim tá e depois quando tiver
adequado o nível de fertina você para de
usar a o ferro né quer quer completar
alguma coisa sim sim obrigada pela pela
pergunta realmente é uma coisa
importante a gente tem visto aí no pós
dengue uma uma questão inflamatória
importante do fígado né os pacientes às
vezes subindo cinco ou seis vezes então
muitas vezes sugiro a você fazer uma
avaliação das enzimas empáticas porque
muitas vezes essa Ferritina tá alta por
conta de uma inflamação hepática
prolongada no pós dengue então Faria
Exatamente isso is não é porque o ferro
tá alto É porque tá inflamado isso TGO
TGP bilirrubina amilase fosfatase
alcalina são exames que você faz de
sangue muitas vezes vão mostrar paraa
senhora e pro médico que lhe prescreve
que o fígado se mantém inflamado aí no
pós dengue então tem pacientes que
chegaram a subir cinco vezes as as
enzimas hepáticas Tá bem então muitas
vezes essa Ferritina ela está alta por
conta da inflamação hepática pós dengue
ou medicamentos que muitas vezes você
tomou durante esse período Então antes
de tudo analisar novamente o número da
Ferritina mas esses outros em conjunto
tá bom isso é porque pode est tendo essa
confusão aí da inflamação do da dengue e
às vezes você pode até precisar mas tem
que tem que ser cautela né tem que e
primeiro desinflamar o seu organismo
rever os níveis de ferritina para depois
decidir que vai
fazer Ah e por enquanto você pode comer
alimentos ricos em ferro que não vão
estourar tanto né porque é diferente uma
suplementação oral de você comer verdura
de folha verde ovos e carne Você tem o
ferro natural alimentar tá bom
isso fta de ferro e Ferritina devida
medul osa que não funciona hum
Não não é bem por isso não acho
perguntando se doenças da medula óssea
podem gerar alterações de ferritina e
ferro provavelmente é o contexto Talvez
o pergunta ten sido formulada de uma
maneira é contexto é esse isso boa noite
estou com fetina acima de 600 devo
consultar o hermat não necessariamente
pode
serista mas pode ser um médico ou médica
que tem um bom conhecimento geral de
medicina não precisa necessariamente ser
um hematologista tá igual a gente falou
Salomão revê a Live de que o aumento de
ferritina pode ser hemocromatose pode
mas antes de tudo investigar outras
causas tá com certeza Ferritina 1950 é
bastante alto Tá bastante alto e pode
ser inclusive ser hemose hemocromatose
tem que dar uma investigada nso
aí qual o tempo máximo para peeti o
exame Você quer dizer mínimo né que é
mínimo que ela tá querendo saber né Não
sei se a Ferritina Ela tá
perguntando depende pode ser eh 60 dias
30 dias Depende da situação
Ok se for para acompanhar o pós dengue
entre TRS semanas a qu sem a mesma que
Peg da dengue não não
é mas talvez seja Mimo contexto
Por que que esse tipo de exame muitas
vezes não é solicitado por alguns
médicos eu entendo como exame de rotina
esse exame Liane eu peço para todo mundo
obviamente que se eu vi uma Ferritina H
alguns meses atrás tá normal não ficou
repetindo com a frequência exagerada mas
é um exame muito básico assim muito de
rotina esse exame de
fetina não posso responder pelos outros
colegas Tá mas é um exame de
rotina por pessoas que inalam hidrogênio
faz em quimioterapia não ficam com
anemia Não não é esse fato que você tá
falando aí não é bem assim tá o
hidrogênio é excelente é ótimo
antioxidante muito bom para câncer
inclusive é um dos melhores
antioxidantes para se utilizar no câncer
tá em algumas situações até o único
antioxidante deve ser utilizado mas eh
não tem nada né porque tá usando
hidrogênio não vai ter anemia tá isso
não faz muito sentido
ã
h o nome do exame é o mesmo nome da Live
Ferritina
tá meu médico out molecular identificou
intolerância ao ferro depois desse
diagnóstico conseguimos combater a
anemia crônica que me atacava desde
criança intolerância talvez intolerância
algum suplemento específico de Ferro né
né Aí você teve que trocar o suplemento
a pelo suplemento B né porque ferro é o
mineral essencial à vida né você não
pode ter uma alergia ferro no sentido de
ter alergia ao mineral ferro Você pode
ter alergia a alguma algum suplemento
alguma intolerância algum suplemento E
trocou o suplemento e pode ter resolvido
o problema a gente tem hoje no mercado
vários suplementos sejam de drogaria
sejam de manipulação que utilizam o
ferro de diversas maneiras Então você
tem o o velho e bom sulfato Ferros que
você pega até no Posto Saúde você tem
outras H alguns outros suplementos no
mercado até em pastilha efervescente já
com vitamina C ou ferro você tem hoje
aquele ferro novo né que você manipula
em gotas que tem uma biodisponibilidade
muito maior então pessoas tomam ferro e
não consigam melhorar migram para esse
suplemento e ele acaba tendo uma melhora
tem menos intolerância gástrica porque
quando você suplementa ferro qualquer
paciente pode ter o quê um pouco mais de
gases o cocô ficar mais preto tem um
pouco de diarreia algumas pessoas têm
constipação então tem pessoas que
desistem da suplementação até mesmo por
esses efeitos da própria medicação não
seriam nem efeitos colaterais né então a
troca às vezes do tipo de entrega de
substância que você usa para suplementar
ajuda a evitar esses problemas né como
suplementar Ferro para quem tem alope
androgenética não não vejo nenhuma
mudança Só porque você tem alope
androgenética inclusive falta de ferro é
uma das causas de queda de cabelo tá por
causa da do da alteração no
funcionamento da tireoide não tem uma
uma diferença Só porque você tem
alopecia androgenética Michele
tá a Carla tá pedindo pra gente falar
sobre peritina B que afeta muitas
mulheres né devido aí a questão
menstrual e principalmente pacientes que
TM irregularidade no no fluxo do sangue
tem miomas né É eu comentei já sobre
isso ao longo da da Live Quer comentar
mais pode comentar não acho que ela tá
perguntando sobre os sintomas geralmente
paciente a mulher né mulher ou homem né
é mais difícil o homem com ferritina
baixa quando você pega um homem com
ferritina baixa você realmente suspeita
aí muito de problemas intestinais de
absorção suspeita bastante de tumor né
porque o tumor é muito consultivo então
quando você pega um homem com anemia o
que não é comum ou com ferritina baixa
você acende a luz amarela pro vermelho
rastrear tumor nesse esse paciente
avaliar melhor o intestino dele né e ver
se não tem alguma situação aí
psiquiátrica de anorexia vegana também
né às vezes é um homem vegano que o
ferro ex consum mas é mais difícil né
isso quando saber que tenho gordura no
fígado é tem várias formas de ver isso
pelo ultrassom pela bi impedância
né mas a pergunta foi para você foi para
mim bem Márcio tudo bem embora não torça
pro seu
time mas eu vou te responder tá eh como
saber se tem gordura no fígado uma das
coisas que às vezes acende a luz é
quando você faz o exame de sangue normal
e vem lá TGO TGP fosfatas alcalina Gama
GT alterada aí você muitas vezes pede um
ultrassom ou às vezes já tem o ultrassom
junto e você vê uma alteração da textura
do fígado então fica um fígado mais
rugoso no ultrassom ou da cor do fígado
e fica um F fando mais branco mais
brilhante sendo que geralmente ele é
mais cino escuro então às vezes você lê
no laudo do ultrassom alteração da
textura alteração da
ecogenicidade isso é um sinal de gordura
de esteatose hepática esteatose é uma
alteração aí dos dos hepatócitos né que
são as células que trabalham ali no
fígado Tá bom então fala assim né Alan
ah eu tô com uma gordurinha no fígado
gente isso é um negócio importante
gordurinha no fígado pode ser n coisas
não é uma coisa assim simples Ah vou
fazer só uma dieta às vezes essa
gordurinha no fígado é por conta de uma
alteração de ferritina por outras coisas
a mais uma Hepatite viral Então tem que
ser investigada tá então no laudo
Geralmente vem assim sinais ecográficos
compatíveis com esteatose grau um dois
ou três ou seja grau leve moderado ou
Grave por aí que se vê tá bom
Márcio sim Mônica é prejudicial à saúde
né O que estávamos falando mais cedo
vocês que não pegaram a Live inteira
depois que tiver terminado tá gravado no
canal vocês podem assistir do começo ao
fim para pegar alguns detalhes que vocês
podem ter perdido porque entraram no
meio da Live
tá remédio para quem tem fertina alta
nós acabamos de falar não é um remédio
específico pode ser sangria né que é
flebotomia transfusão de sangue
tratamento da inflamação e da condição
subjacente tá provocando essa inflamação
e também em algumas situações
específicas mais raro usar uso quelantes
né usar substâncias que pegam um ferro
tiram do
organismo Ah é uma coisa que eu não
comentei existe um tratamento
homeopático para para ferro alto que eu
uso bastante que baixa em torno de 20%
os níveis de ferro também ajuda bastante
além de você reduzir a o consumo de
ferro você corta a carne vermelha e
existe uns alimentos que o caso do arroz
vermelho arroz negro que ajudam a tirar
o ferro do organismo tá com tá em
excesso intoxicação medicamentos do
fígado causa Alta ou baixa feritina
geralmente a fertina alta ok
tem um comentário aqui do João áo alfal
lipoico ajuda na redução Com certeza
ajuda na redução da Ferritina porque
alfal lipoico além de ser um agente
antioxidante e antiinflamatório ele
também é excelente pro pro fígado por
isso que ele abaixa reduzir a ajuda a
reduzir a feritina
Marlene eu tô vendo aqui nossa é
complicado é sim é complicado é uma é
uma situação por isso que não tem não
não existe eh pílula mágica na verdade
você tem que avaliar o paciente de cima
em baixo tá Ah tô com a ferritin alta
vou fazer sangria vou fazer transfusão
não você tem que achar sempre quem é a
causa senão você fica a vida inteira
tratando sintoma né como acontece em
muitos lugares isso fitina tava 43
parece que é um homem Rodrigo Silva
bolsa de Ferro três semanas chegou a 121
Qual a melhor forma de manter a fertina
normal se você não for vegano não tiver
problema quanto a isso é comer carne
vermelha fígado é muito bom não precisa
ser cru não tá você pode comer fígado
uma vez por semana mas não precisa ser
cru tá você pode comer fta de 200 g de
fígado aí por semana que tá de bom
tamanho
tá isso aqui já foi
respondido Ahã
[Música]
tem muita coisa fora de
contexto depois que perdi um um dente
com amálgama antigo que estava me
intoxicando os suplementos hepáticos
começaram a fazer
efeito mas ainda estou tendo sequelas
tratando
sequelas interessante é é importante
realmente tirar os amálgamas né porque
são uma fonte de intoxicação com
Mercúrio que pode est poderia estar
sobrecarregando o seu fígado
suplementos bruta na forma reduzida
clorela ácido afalp poico e na São
suficientes para substituir a
flebotomia depende né são bons
suplementos são ótimos clorela ótimo
para fazer detox do fígado uma fonte
também muito interessante aí de
nutrientes salf lipoico já comentamos o
nac ele é um dos aminoácidos que formam
a
glutationa todos eles vão ajudar o
fígado todos eles vão ser
antioxidantes vão ajudar a desinflamar
mas nem sempre vão ser suficientes Às
vezes tem que associar isso à flebotomia
tá é avaliar o paciente de perto né
fez-se o diagnóstico iniciou a o
tratamento a suplementação e tá com esse
paciente de perto na questão de
avaliação dos sintomas clínicos e
laboratoriais de repente ter que se
associar à Flot tomia ou não Tá então é
tá de perto né não não não deixar
escorrer é totalmente possível Ferritina
alta e ferro baixo sim Raimundo Ok Esse
é um caso clássico de pessoa que tá com
fetina alta por inflamação e não por
excesso de ferro no
organismo e a situação da disbiose em
relação ao ferro cérico Não entendi sua
pergunta José Amorin você entendeu Acho
que ele tá perguntando sobre pacientes
que TM questões de inflamação intestinal
disbiose pode alterar o ferro cérico por
ã síndrome desab sortiva se um paciente
que tem síndrome inflamatório intestinal
pode ter mais anemia por alteração na
absorção do ferro pode com certeza né
pode ter uma anemia ferropriva por falta
de absorção de Ferro né menopausa pode
aumentar sim porque na menopausa você
não menstrua e aumenta o depósito de
ferro no organismo aumenta a Ferritina é
muito comum Exclusive nã e se você tiver
com processo inflamatório um
hipotiroidismo iniciando
um obesidade um pré-diabetes também
levam a
a alteração da Ferritina aí não porque
você parou de menstruar mas por uma
questão inflamatória tá Mônica Ana nós
comentamos isso mais para trás tá depois
você assiste o vídeo gravado que eu acho
que talvez tenha entrado Só
agora estou amando assistir essa Live
Passei duas semanas com a minha irmã
devido a fertina estar alta deu
alteração no fígado mas ela teve que
tomar vitamina B12 mas são contextos
diferentes né a Ferritina a B12 ã muitas
vezes ela teve uma alteração no no na
B12 por falta de absorção ou a dieta
dela tá ruim ou ela tem uma alteração
genética que não não absorve melhor a
B12 são questões diferentes você tem a
gente acha muito aqui no consultório uma
paciente que tem problemas de metilação
depois vocês dão uma olhada no canal
sobre os vídeos sobre metilação quem tem
mutação do mthf
em que o paciente tem ferritina baixa e
B12 Baixa também então São pessoas que
às vezes TM muitas questões vasculares
muita fadiga muita questão autoimune
também tá então muitas vezes o que ela
tem aí é uma uma situação genética ser
também
investigada acabamos de falar disso
Sil Olha que eu saiba não eh é um
tratamento para fetina sérica alta iodo
iodeto tá iodo iodeto Vai ter outras
funções aí suporte vários órgãos do
organismo principalmente o a tireoide né
mas também estômago próstata mama e por
aí vai mas não para baixar Ferritina
Tá sim então você passou com o médico
que viu a estava alto mandou patologista
tudo bem eh pode ser uma conduta mas eu
geralmente não encaminho não não vejo
necessidade de fazer isso tanto eu
quanto D Ana Paula sabemos tratar isso A
não ser que seja um caso que tá com
suspeita de uma doença medula óssea
algum câncer tudo algum câncer
hematológico mas 90% das vezes ou mais a
gente não caminha não porque não é uma
necessidade
tá e hemoglobina 16 é bem alta
hemoglobina hein não tem útero é
preocupante pode ser porque essa
hemoglobina ficar bastante alta Você
pode ter aumento de risco de trombos tá
de o sangue fic Grosso demais também tem
que ver o contexto às vezes ela é
fumante às vezes você é fumante ou esum
ou tá obesa ou toma um pouquinho mais de
álcool Tá comendo muito carboidrato tá
aumenta hemoglobina Com certeza mas tem
que avaliar o contexto como Paula disse
né como eu já falei a gente não Analisa
exames em live tá não podemos fazer isso
tá
hã a intolerância ao ferro foi
identificada em alimentos e
fitoterápicos ricos em
ferro vegetais verdes escuros não causam
reação intestinal estufamento tratamos
com oligoelementos para reter o ferro é
aquela paciente tava falando é a mesmo
que falou que tinha intolerância a ferro
né OK a aqui uma uma coisa legal pós da
Aparecida pós dengue queda de cabelo
pode ser de ferro ou de ou derretimento
não entende o derretimento no pós dengue
Você lembra mais ou menos igual a pós
covid né Você tem uma inflamação
sistêmica enorme né os pacientes ficam
muito depal perados muitos muito perde
apetite fica com anorexia Não come outro
tem diarreias importantíssimas perdem
seis a 8 kg então o pós dengue realmente
o os o período da dengue e as três
primeiras semanas depois você pode ter
uma alteração nutricional muito muito
importante Tá bom então se você perdeu
nutriente inflamou fígado Com certeza a
queda de cabelo pode ser um sintoma isso
que já comentamos tá ainé depois você
assiste a Live desde o começo que você
vai ver essa a resposta pra sua pergunta
aí
[Música]
Ah pode ter sim uma interferência no
café com absorção de Ferro tá então é
bom evitar de tomar café junto com
ferro suplementar uma em cápsula uns 65
MG Depende você tá falando tem vários
suplementos de ferro no mercado
Tá primeiro começa com a alimentação né
avalia aí os exames de ferro e começa
com A alimentação tem tomem cuidado com
a automedicação muita gente tomando
suplemento aí sem acompanhamento de
exames e depois vem os pepinos né gente
o o ferro ele não acompanha
necessariamente a Ferritina tá é
perfeitamente normal o ferro Está ok e a
fertina baixa isso porque está
absorvendo um pouco o ferro porque você
é um paciente que fez cirurgia
bariátrica né Eu acho que cabe
reforçá-lo Quem ainda não quem não
prestou atenção ou não entendeu o começo
da Live que está entrando agora a
diferença ferro é uma coisa como o
doutor falou é um mineral e Ferritina é
outra coisa vocês estão confundido Ah o
ferro tem que tá alto a Ferritina tem
que tá alta O ferro tem que tá baixo a
fertina que são coisas diferentes que
podem estar os dois altos os dois baixos
um alto outro baixo né sim porque assim
o em termos de depósito de ferro no
organismo a Ferritina é muito mais
fidedigna que o ferro O ferro é é o é o
que a o organismo vai usar naquele
momento imagina que você tem uma casa
que você tem uma dispensa nessa casa e
você comprou sei lá 10 kg de arroz 10 kg
de arroz certo então você tem uma um um
stock de arroz na sua casa né às vezes
na sua cozinha a moça que trabalha para
você ou Você cozinhou pouco arroz tem
pouco arroz lá cozinhar tá cozido pouco
arroz lá na panela e aí você olhando só
pra panela ah não tá faltando arroz na
casa não tá você vai lá na dispensa tem
arroz então e pode acontecer o contrário
tá com a panela cheia de arroz e acabou
o arroz da da dispensa então a dispensa
é Ferritina e o arroz na panela é o
ferro então e para você dizer se essa
casa tá faltando arroz ou não é melhor
olhar dispensa do que ficar olhando a
panela se tem pouco arroz ou muito arroz
uhum foi boa essa minha analogia Oi
então Que bom acho que deu para entender
melhor
assim abraço para você viu gan beijo no
coração
também
Ah seu
e uma coisa importante né muitos
pacientes às vezes vão fazer cirurgia e
tão com alterações do ferro e da
Ferritina então avaliar direitinho antes
de fazer uma cirurgia Como tá seu nível
de ferro e fetina Porque isso pode
prejudicar muito tanto a anestesia como
a cicatrização tá deixa eu virar um
pouquinho mais para cá que você tá
ficando fora do é melhor ficar me cortar
do que cortar você verdade a aqui acho
que tá complementando uma pergunta
anterior aqui quando minha minha
Ferritina foi a 43 passei a comer 500 g
de carne tá parecendo eu meu troglodita
né meu comendo carne para caramba e 5
meses depois minha Ferritina tinha caído
para
41 Como pode isso Provavelmente você tá
Ah não tá absorvendo o ferro de maneira
suficiente tem que analisar o seu
intestino Rodrigo se você não tá com uma
um problema de absorção intestinal
beleza
Bel quem tem mioma tende a sangrar mais
na menstruação e tende a ter deficiência
de Ferro né todo mundo que tem miom vai
ter deficiência de Ferro tá só as que
tiverem sangramento só as que tiverem
sangramento é
exagerado panela de ferro aumenta o
ferro prego no feijão aumenta o ferro
prego no feijão as mães colocavam
antigamente
Peg não peguei a minha mãe não fazia
isso não minha mãe me poupou dessa aí ó
Que bacana
Ahã então Cida o problema na tireide
veio por conta da ferritina baixa certo
eu tava comentando mais
mais cedo na Live aí né porque a
tireoide para funcionar bem Cida ela
precisa de alguns micronutrientes
importantes tá então me corrija por
favor
B12 ferro D Ômega magnésio selênio zinco
e odo certo cobre também vitamina D
magnésio é então se você tem você tá com
uma alteração de Ferro principalmente
para baixo a sua tiroide começa a
funcionar meio que com um carro que tá
andando com uma gasolina adulterada ela
não performa bem então muitas vezes se
isso é contínuo essa tireóide ela entra
em disfunção tá então por isso que
muitas vezes não é só dar ali o o Puran
o sintro não você tem que dar nutrição
para essa tireoide adequada tá algumas
até pegam no tranco e volta a funcionar
exato então Esso que ela já respondeu
sim pode ajudar um pouco apesar de ser
um ferro pouco disponível para absorção
pode ajudar um pouco sim o panela de
ferro
tá na verdade o ferro mais absorvido é o
ferro que está
na na carne vermelha nos alimentos de
origem animal porque o ferro já está na
forma M lá é mais fácil de absorver tá
do que o ferro inorgânico que tem nos
vegetais ou que tem na na panela por
exemplo tá quer dizer nos vegetais não
chega a ser inorgânico mas não tá na
forma de de m então a absorção é mais
difícil Obrigada Rosângela de Manaus
abraços
obrigada Marcelo obrigada aí a gente tá
aqui para ajudar orientar e vocês também
pegarem as informações e usarem isso nas
suas consultas com os colegas
Irani
Obrigada estava tomando as pirulina em
clorela e me falaram que não pode para
quem tem problema de tireoide não não
concordo com isso não Cida ao contrário
é ela não vai atrapalhar de forma alguma
ajuda que lá metal pesado que altera
tireoide dá suporte deodo dá suporte de
Ferro tá e espirulina para mulher ainda
é bom né que ajuda a pele unha cabelo
celulite existe anemia por vários
motivos Elsa uma delas é a anemia
ferropriva que por falta de ferro Ok
quando você tá com falta de ferro como
eu falei onde é que você vai olhar na
panela ou na dispensa né você vai olhar
na dispensa que é a Ferritina certo
então você vai procurar avaliar a
ferritina baixa para concluir que essa
pessoa lógico no próprio hemograma a
massa vai tá hipocrômica né como com vai
est pouco vermelha e ela vai est
microcítica ela vai est pequena então
essa aí é uma eh é é um palpite grande
que pode ser uma anemia por falta de
ferro tá anemia hipocrômica e
microcítica E aí você analisa na
feritina junto você vai concluir que a
anemia dessa pessoa por deficiência de
Ferro olha aqui uma pergunta
interessante do Álvaro Álvaro Boa noite
obrigada você tá aqui no canal espero
que você continue com a gente nos outras
slides na minha família meu pai e irmão
tem Ferritina alta a minha é bem mais
alta porque eu tenho hepatite C como a
gente falou depois volta o vídeo Vê com
carinho hepatite C Altera a função do
fígado alterando função do fígado eu vou
ter alteração na Ferritina certo como o
doutor falou alguns sintomas de
ferritina podem acontecer né até mesmo
na parte vascular que a a é a perna
ficar escura Tá certo então existem
alimentos que você pode usar existem
suplementos fitoterápicos que você pode
usar tá então a hepatite C sim pode
aumentar a Ferritina Tá bom gilan
obrigada pelo abraço gan Gilvan sempre
muito gentil gentil e carinhoso com a
gente aqui a Jane tem uma pergunta
interessante aqui também Jane como se
mede odo minha avó teve Bosso minha mãe
tir ti rimoto ambas podem ser
hereditárias sim as patologias de
tiroide são tem principalmente nódulo né
hipotiroidismo tudo Hashimoto tem mais
um um uma questão de
eh né ambiental né agora O iodo Você
mede pelo sangue e pela urina sendo que
O
iodo é saliva também mas às vezes é mais
difícil da pessoa
conseguir existe aí várias maneiras você
pode olhar só o iodo urinário Mas se
você quiser ter uma visão super Clara é
bom você correlacionar O iodo salivar
com o iodo urinário Tá mas é um exame
que também é de exceção não é um exame
de rotina não
ah eu acho que tá bom Néa deixa eu ver
se tem mais alguma coisa Aparecida
espero ter te ajudado tá legal Cida
muito obrigada Eliseu Como sempre muito
obrigada muito legal suas perguntas tá a
gente deu oportunidade hoje para
bastante gente conversar né Lembrando
que essa Live fica gravada você pode
assistir fazer suas anotações
compartilha ajuda o canal a manter a
qualidade dos vídeos a frequência tá tem
nosso Instagram meu @aninha do Artur
o Artur um dia vai ter do Alan @dr laim
e foi do Instagram que a gente teve essa
ideia então mandem sugestões tá bom
compartilhem os vídeos a gente vai poder
ajud vocês pra de muita ajuda de vocês
porque a plataforma Ela Não Está
entregando mais tá então você pode estar
assinado no canal às vezes tira
eh e a plataforma mudou totalmente a
maneira de entregar os vídeos para vocês
por causa da concorrência não vou ficar
falando nomes aqui para atrapalhar o
vídeo mas se você gosta do material se
você gosta do nosso trabalho eh faz o
seguinte toda semana dá uma checadinha
no canal não fica esperando eh só os
vídeos que a plataforma te oferece lá
naquela linha do tempo da plataforma que
você vai olhando os vídeos que te
oferece vai também no canal tá eu faço
isso por exemplo eu eu sigo YouTubers
que falam de viagem
internacionalização comparação entre
países que fala sobre a inteligência
artificial sobre história então eu vou
lá no canal do Joãozinho do Pedrinho
assistir o vídeo mais recente do
Pedrinho do Joãozinho então vocês façam
também se vocês gostarem do material vão
lá no canal Vê o vídeo que te interessa
tá lembra que tem vídeos antigos que
talvez vocês não não conheçam Então sai
um pouquinho da zona de conforto porque
a plataforma hoje não tá entregando mais
tá ela não tá mais avisando vocês de
vídeos novos tá o canal já tem vários
meses tá tendo problemas então se você
quer que o o conteúdo continue é muito
importante que vocês ajudem e também
Compartilhando os vídeos com os seus
amigos e familiares Michele muito
obrigada
Irani Adriana Antônio Roma Lu Lene tá
irmã muito obrigada mesmo tá bom a gente
vai estar esperando e lembra né que a
gente tem aí uma frequência dos vídeos
no canal tem um shorts também o
Instagram e é o que ele falou você põe
ali na lupinha o assunto se você pôr na
lupa agora do canal alind Dutra e
Ferritina alind Dutra e ferro ala ind
Dutra e eh hepatite ã esteatose vão ter
vários vídeos são quase 1000 vídeos na
plataforma daqui a pouco completa o anos
de 1000 vídeos né porque muitos vídeos
tiveram que ser retirados mas já passou
muito tempo de de 1000 vídeos né Então
pessoal e convença essa senhora que a
participar mais do do do canal entendeu
vou participar o pessoal lá no Instagram
e me curtir compartilhar e falar o
assunto que quer hein Instagram da Dra
Ana Paula drinha vou escrever aqui ó
essa semana eu falei sobre tireoide e
doenças cardiovasculares que é a outra
carta na manga para outra Live Tá então
vamos lá para vocês mandarem as
perguntas lá no Direct ou nos
comentários pra gente poder fazer uma
live bem bacana sobre tireoide doença
cardiovascular Adriana já fizemos de
endometriose no passado viu excelente
com a d valene isso dá uma ol dá uma
olhadinha podemos fazer de novo mas dá
uma olhadinha lá no no canal OK
tá Doutora top é muito melhor aqui eu
com certeza Doutora top aí
ó pessoal Muito obrigado um beijo no
coração de vocês nós nos vemos na
próxima Live nos próximos vídeos vocês
são esa isso tchau tchau pessoal tchau
tchau ah